with so much emphasis
on mask wearing and hand sanitizing it's
easy for the routine things to
slip through the cracks in today's buddy
check eight denise valdez has a reminder
for women
to not put off taking care of themselves
in this month's buddy check 8 report
women right now might be feeling
stretched a little thin
maybe their home helping their kids with
distance learning
taking care of family members or just
scrambling to provide for their families
but it is critical especially during a
pandemic for women to take care of
themselves
dr suzanne ellied from the comprehensive
cancer center
says her practice like everything else
is running under a new normal
a patient who's been waiting weeks or
even months for surgery
may run into an unexpected delay
amazingly enough i've had to cancel
few surgeries some of the patients whose
temperature was normal
totally asymptomatic before the surgery
with the routine testing when covet-19
test was done they tested positive
so now they had to go home quarantined
for 14 days
delay the surgery for 14 days and then
do the surgery
when they test negative again so that we
don't expose the whole operating room
team to the cog19 well that's a surprise
right when someone doesn't have a
temperature
you know they're dealing with one
medical issue and now pops up
the virus exactly she says the american
cancer society estimates more than 270
000 women will be diagnosed with breast
cancer this year
so despite everything going on in the
world do your monthly breast self exam
and never be afraid to ask questions and
get answers
women are the caretakers they take care
of everybody else
and then they take care of themselves
we're here to remind them you have to be
healthy to be
able to take care of your family so
that's why on the eighth of every month
we urge you to call your buddy and do
your breast self exam
we have more information and a list of
resources like where you can get a
mammogram
on our buddy check eight page of 8 news
now